how to stop your work from being stolen
so I got a great question I kind of sad
question front of my youtube viewers
love you guys Patrick David who wrote in
the say so much of my work has been
stolen by other people who use it to
advance themselves in their career how
can I stop this as a season possible and
I now feel like a worthless individual
I'm poor I'm humble I'm not a violent
person my circumstances allow me to be
all over and since I no longer have
anything to give to the world I feel
like there is no room for young men I
give up help me help you Patrick you
can't give up man you cannot give up
because that means that they won and as
a young man as a young person still a
lot of brightness ahead of them you got
to remember that this you know you have
you still have a lot of time left man
and you cannot stop pursuing whatever
your ideas are I'm going to give you
three ways to help prevent future work
from being stolen hopefully helps answer
your question number one is protect
yourself now I don't know what kind of
ideas you have but if it's a business
idea you can get a patented you might
want to look at getting something
copyrighted you know whatever is being
stolen it's worth talking to an
intellectual property lawyer and seeing
is this something I can protect and how
to do it again I don't know specifics of
your case but I with more details you
can figure it out number two is change
your surroundings it kind of feels like
the people around you are screwing you
over again you are too specific in the
email but it feels like the people who
are in your life who maybe you
collaborate with our are not the
greatest people and they're stealing
your ideas you got to change your
surroundings and this could be a great
moment for you write that the highly
successful people in the world a lot of
them have had huge hardships and have
been screwed over many times in the past
and they learn from that now I think of
Walt Disney who was a struggling artist
trying to figure out his art business
how to make this a go as a struggling
cartoonist and not knowing how we'd ever
make money and being poor and you know
having to sleep at his office and eat
beans because he didn't have enough
money to survive and his first creation
was a cartoon called Oswald the Lucky
Rabbit
and he created it and he you know
started making some money off of it and
then he found out that the dealer that
he went through the agency that he
worked with to land a deal the contract
that he signed gave them complete
control over his creation so think about
it like he was struggling he's he's
living in his office eating beans you
know not enough money to survive he
finally makes his big brick he finally
gets it to go through he gets it has his
creation Oswald the Lucky Rabbit and and
he makes a little bit of money and then
and then they steal it away from him and
he's got nothing he's going to start all
over again and the idea for Mickey Mouse
his next creation came from you know the
place that he was staying had mice in it
right that's how great a place it was I
had mice and one of them was really
friendly to him and he wanted to create
a cartoon character after that Mouse and
so he turned that adversity into
strength and created something new and
you can bet that when he created Mickey
Mouse and started to market and promote
it he owned it right he wasn't making
that same mistake again so what ever
happened to you you've learned the
lesson you're still young you've learned
the lesson and use that for your next
brief thing that you create another
example that I remember is from Sam
Walton he's the founder of Walmart he
became one of the richest people in the
world and his first location he rented
from the landlord that was in the
building and and the the landlord saw
how successful it was that when Sam
Walton came to renew the lease he said
no I don't want to renew the lease and
he refused to give sam walton his
location and then he had to he had to
leave and the landlord set up the same
business in the same location think
about you spend so much time investing
in building up a business in marketing
and getting people to come and then to
just have it swooped out from under you
and have to start all over again and
have your landlord take it over for you
it sucks and
Sam Walton and Walt Disney could have
given up and said this sucks you know my
life is over I'm gonna go just get a job
and hate the rest of my life and give up
or they can go back and get to work and
start something new and not make that
same mistake again you can bet the Sam
Walton was never going to sign another
short-term lease I get in his life he
learned the valuable lesson it made him
a better entrepreneur and he learned
from it so change your surroundings
right you want to be surrounded by the
people who are supportive of what you do
who aren't screwing you over who believe
in the mission that you're on and I
really feel like the people in your life
right now aren't aren't helping you on
your path number three ignore and move
on listen the past is the past right you
do not gain anything by continuing the
heart over the past you learn from the
mistakes and you move on I've had a lot
of stuff happened to me I've had people
screw me over and deals i've had people
do crazy things for their own promotion
that damage me you know i had a woman
who set up a Facebook page pretending to
be married to me saying she was my wife
and then started you know trying to sell
products and saying that I endorse this
stuff that I like I even know who this
woman was what she was selling and
somebody on my in my community alerted
me to it it's like like this happens the
more important the mission you're on the
maury trying to change the world the
bigger you get the bigger your ideas are
the more people are going to try to
knock you down are going to try to steal
a little bit of your light but you have
to keep going and you can't stop because
when you stop they win and you got to
remember the long run you're going to be
the winner not them you're going to be
the winner because you're creating new
ideas that's just one idea that one idea
of yours those five ideas of yours fine
see they were all storm you've got a
million more great ideas coming because
that's the kind of person you are
because you're creative entrepreneur
ready to take on the world work those
people you know they'll talk about some
serious little man those people they
can't create anything they're never
going to win long-term so they made a
little bit of money off of this thing
fine they're never going to be able to
export it to become anything
great because they can't cope with the
creative ideas at UK so the long-term
you win but you have to keep going you
can't give up this is just a start man
you're young you got a bright future
ahead of you and you got to keep going
so remember how to stop your work from
being stolen number one protect yourself
number to change your surroundings
number three ignore and move on and
believe for those you're watching you
like the video you can subscribe to the
channel see more just like it thank you
so much and I will see you soon if you
want more belief energy running through
your veins sign up for the newsletter
below it's free you're gonna love it hi
I'm Jason jayraj fonseka of ra's online
com and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and XD only newsletter i prioritize and
look forward to period